here we are on the couch now that we're
in our off season we're trying something
a little bit new
where we watch old worth it videos and
provide
the never-before-heard commentary about
how they were made what we enjoyed
making about them
chilling eating some snacks yeah adam
what are we doing today
watching the first episode together
and so that's not the first worth of
video it's the first worth of video
where adam and i
joined stephen post keith season one
episode three okay all right this is the
oh my gosh i'm so happy to watch this
right now it's the pizza episode look at
me
got some candy corn on my desk so young
and spry
yeah how's it going oh my gosh look at
that haircut
she actually is not available right now
but steven you look like uh
yeah okay you look like the main videos
um this is terrible i can't believe i
had sunglasses on my shirt like that
what am i thinking why did i do that
you thought you would try to look cool
in a video which is
it's a a phrase you could apply to all
choices you've ever made
i mean look look at this it's the same
guy
oh my gosh so where are we going okay
pause
the title of the video was just pizza
time
whose idea was that i'm pretty sure that
was adam's idea
is that true i don't remember okay i do
know that he did the coloring for this
because i'm not
smart enough to make the background
change colors like that this title looks
like one where
you had made something that was even
worse and then adam was just like
i'm just deleting it and writing pizza
time yeah we gotta we gotta get this on
the internet
exactly where are we going we are on our
way right now to eat three different
pizzas
should i be saying pause like that
you can tell we were all like got a big
video to make because we all have really
new haircuts why do you need me to come
with you
because i need a partner in crime you
are the best friend today
let me look up some dynamic duos and
then we can decide which one this was
um your call out here
was a monumental moment for worth it i
don't if you hadn't said this
and ashley olsen we may not be this far
and we wouldn't have this line and adam
wouldn't have been made in infamy
that haircut was entirely too tight
yeah so this was at the start of the
show where i really didn't know what we
were doing
and i was just there to join you on the
shoot like you had set up all the
details
i was along for the ride location is and
twenty five cents that value right there
yeah this is when
we really try to make the cheap foods
really cheap
yeah this is a five dollar pizza
that is so like how many highs does this
location make in a day we've done over
1200
that's a lot of
we're just in the direct center of a
fully busy
kitchen i don't know how we got away
with that
that's not a thing we would set up oh
yeah it's a great pizza this pizza's
called a simple pie
it's very simple and i think that's how
you usually do things online five
dollars you're getting
the three things that make pizza pizza
you had good dough you had good sauce
you had good cheese this sauce is
delicious
have you had this sauce yeah
it's part of the other pizza so we got
the most expensive pizza here and it's
7.95
cheers oh yeah i was not down with
cheersing either
i was fully anti-cheersing i was like
get your
pizza tip away from me oh my gosh or a
pizza please it's pretty good
next place that simple pie was great but
i would spend the extra three dollars
wow very short taste test very short
yeah nice and snappy
i don't even think we really learned how
the pizza was made oh that pizza effect
graphic
what the heck
[Laughter]
what is this hello okay all right we're
talking let's talk about simpler time
you know i actually kind of like it
better you know how sports teams do like
throwback
jerseys yeah for like one game a season
we should do a throwback episode of
worth it where
you get the aviators on your jacket we
do the
dorky graphics look at that graphic
that wood grain
see we this was the fun stuff man
eating this popsicle [ __ ] chill out and
hang out so we're gonna make a brownie
pizza for you today i was so excited
that you picked pizzeria moza
for this location i was like this is
this okay i'll go on this video we're
like back to this place
that's right do you know where we were
going before we started
um i think i found out like the day
before okay but you already agreed to it
yeah nice and then it gets [ __ ] up a
little bit
i mean oh my god the sunglasses yeah you
even maintained it in the interview you
were like
i have to meet this chef i'm going to
this nice restaurant
sunglasses but it's actually the crust
[Music]
oh wow that is so good this pizza comes
in quarters i think that
that pizza is ridiculously yeah by the
way it's insane
23 bucks
[Music]
i think that would have been my first
time eating i'm calling it right now
we're not going to tell you
you truly were a pizza please i just got
into the crust
the way that really fresh popcorn tastes
got like flopper
hair coming out of the crust how are you
not excited about this
do you get what i'm talking about you
know what's also interesting the pepper
yes i love pudding i also kind of didn't
know what my
taste test guy persona would be so i was
like should i
try to analyze flavors what am i doing
yeah
well this show actually started off with
us me and keith raiding foods and then
we were like this doesn't feel right at
all these are all great food
it feels much better i think the thing
we realized is
it's more fun if we just find goofy
analogies to make about the really great
details of the food yeah
instead of actually trying to talk about
it national space station can you
imagine eating pizza in space and i'd be
pissed off that they sent me pizza hut
pizza is good what are you talking about
if you're
sending it all the way to space they
could go ahead and send you the best
pizza
if there's any pizza i would want in
space it probably would be delivery
pizza
i feel like it'd be better to eat i
don't know
i feel like it'd be better to eat a
calzone in space
oh wait wait for this transition oh it's
gone already
never mind but adam did a really cool
transition
i remember thinking oh yeah we found the
guy to
to make the show what that one oh the
screen
that i had never that is an adam bianchi
classic you can see it in
all sorts of buzzfeed videos going back
through time that guy went to thanks
goal
the thing where in one shot a body
crosses frame
and then it's keyframed to reveal the
next shot
yeah also you guys missed the one from
uh this location oh yeah there's a
hidden one yeah no no there's one for
sure
i remember yeah
that is smooth oh my gosh i like the way
that pizza just
on the back on the dude remember when we
use classical music for
all of our high-end locations yeah
yeah i love this guy's glasses frames on
white chocolate pizza that's in season
right now what's so special
in the truffle truffles are fungus and
they grow under the ground oh my gosh
my first time having truffle yeah i
was it my first time i think like an
actual real
shaved to order truffle this was my
first time as well too
can we pause real quick and talk about
truffle i just want to clear it up out
there
i have this bad reputation that i think
was
emphasized by ryan and shane from
unsolved especially
that i'm just this like gold grub and
truffle boy
i think it's kind of funny but i'm not
i'm not that i
like i just enjoy good food sometimes
trouble can be good on certain foods
so i'm not helping my case at all yeah i
feel like you try to say
i'm not this pretentious guy and then
you're like i only accept truffle
in the appropriate setting no i'm just
saying
that i'm not all about the truffle i'm
not always all about the truffle
you're not helping your kids dang it
real wood fired oven this will get
somewhat uh
smokier once it comes out what
okay i did i definitely did not put that
shot in
that was my that must be an adam bianchi
special
so fun fact can we pause real quick
not there so at this time adam and i
actually worked
on tasty yeah and we had recently been
doing a video series where we are
inviting chefs in to make tasty videos
and so in like the last couple of months
we had actually worked with wolfgang
puck
it was the like one of the craziest
shoots i'd ever been on
i was star struck he comes in with this
whole entourage of
other chefs with like carts and all the
prepared foods
he's so good on camera so personable
and i was like cool we're going back to
a wolfgang puck restaurant i wonder if
he'll be there
and we're like interviewing this guy
who's like the actual day-to-day
executive chef it was very good
and then while we're doing the interview
i noticed in the corner of my eye
wolfgang puck is just walking around
with like a box of cabbages
i think he shows up in the background of
one is he really yeah is that him there
no no that's not him
and i was like wait a second wolfgang
puck is just hanging out in the bed
there he is
he's right there oh and i was like that
is such a cool thing here we are talking
to the main chef of this restaurant
and the owner wolfgang puck is just kind
of like puttering around in the
background
that's like and and that's like the real
life
that worth it you know portrays i think
yeah hey there it is again yeah
showcasing the seasonality
and sharing this beautiful ingredient
wow 135 dollars for like a 12-inch pizza
wow i already learned today that wine
goes delightfully
with pizza are you ready for this i
don't know look at that slow motion tip
touch
wow it's so dramatic i used to really
take a lot of time
building these sequences yeah like i
would spend
hours or days even finding music for
these you would work
so hard constructing this classical
music thing
and then like 10 episodes later people
are like
oh this is the show where they just do
the slow emotion in class no people
love that stuff people were divided i
mean it's like old town road right now
so something i just said in this taste
test was
my goodness i'm eating this expensive
pizza
i'm realizing now that it may never be
surpassed again in my life
and then like a year later we were
eating a 2 000 pizza
and fried chicken with caviar on it
which pizza was better though
which pizza was better um yeah this one
yes this pizza was better than the two
thousand dollar pizza
but i would say the cheapest new york
pizza was better than all of them yeah
it is the best pizza i've ever had
in my entire life if i ordered this and
this dining room were full other diners
would be jealous
the plate wait i think that back
actually turning their heads is my
friend having troubles
wow i'm a vulgar dude also your hair is
crazy by the end of this
this was all shot in the same day right
like we used to shoot these i made
a very clear point to shoot four
episodes in one day
to maintain the integrity of the show
yeah
so i'm looking a little frazzled we're
full other diners would be jealous
the plate would come by they'd all
should be turning their heads
what's that smell that smell is my
dinner what's up what's the livestream
finally what did you say there that
smells my dinner
and enjoy each bite
also i don't i don't think anybody who's
actually dining at spago is going to be
jealous of anybody else's dinner
everybody's balling out at that
restaurant
because we're best friends now
hey that's a pretty good uh throw didn't
i throw one
wait adam is eating the pizza in the
back yeah that was it
that was that was a staple of the show
as well
spago was truly an out of body but that
wasn't a pizza that was a truffle dish
that happened to come
on a pizza i will also have to go with
pizzeria mozart that brought you
was a game some of the world's mysteries
have been
brought to an end
just just give me one mouthful
[Laughter]
oh my gosh i need that effect because
i'm crazy
wow and what a wild ride how long was
that video
that was seven seven fifty five no
way we used to really bang through these
755 that is i that's outrageous
that's half of our video length these
days and i don't know this is
interesting at all
but um we shot this video on a wednesday
hmm yeah that's nice
how do you remember i remember because
me
and adam wednesday night thursday night
friday night and saturday morning yeah
spent every waking moment in the office
editing this video do you remember this
we shot it wednesday and it went on the
internet on sunday
wild all right that was the uh first
watching experience you know this makes
me feel like we're on a
terrace house when they watch the other
people in the
are you gonna watch sarah's house i've
seen it familiar
anyway this was uh a lot funner than i
thought it would be
so what should we call this ah
worth it postmortem yes encroach on that
unsolved territory a little more
[Music]